dozier porter going to try it again  looks good is good and porter just  raining down paint until michael don't  do too much you've been great  what somebody says something in a [ __ ]  he does a little spin then  you know comment  she's playing with such confidence right  now now porter's got 28  and 13. a little  snooty phase there jokic triple double  12 10  10. barton with 20. murray with 19  dozen mike i can't let you go without  asking about that three and the corner  where you did your spin you knew it was  going in walk me through it  i didn't know it i mean i kind of knew i  was going to i didn't really know i  turned back just to make sure but uh  i was just feeling good having fun so i  did it um  and it was it was it was pretty cool so  what was the face you made to  charlotte's bench there  you can't see it through the mask but  i'll let them know for sure  congrats on the wind